we of course begin with the coronavirus
and president Trump who has now approved
major disaster declarations for New York
California and Washington state to
respond to the corona virus pandemic
here is where we stand as of this
morning more than 35,000 people in the
United States reported to be infected by
the corona virus outbreak more than 470
people have died eight states have now
ordered people to stay home to help slow
the spread this applies to more than 100
million people or nearly one in three
Americans on Capitol Hill senators are
back to negotiating this morning after
they failed to agree on a nearly two
trillion dollar relief bill all this as
one senator has tested positive for the
corona virus Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill
Nancy are we actually getting any closer
to a deal Anthony leaders tell us they
are close and that they hope they can
wrap up their talks this morning after
negotiating past midnight here at the
Capitol Republicans say they have
already made big concessions they've
already agreed to what some are calling
unemployment insurance on steroids where
the government would pay laid off
workers their previous salary for up to
four months but Democrats were upset
about what they called a new slush fund
in this bill five hundred billion
dollars to help major companies that
money would be sent out at the
discretion of Treasury secretary
minuchin with limited oversight there is
agreement on a 350 billion dollar
package of grants and loans for small
businesses that could help keep them
afloat for up to eight weeks as well as
those cash payments of $1,200 to workers
who make up to $75,000 a year that'll
help a lot too Republican leader Mitch
McConnell is still eager to hold a final
vote on all of this today all senators
wanting to send that reassuring message
to the markets to businesses and to
workers yeah absolutely Nancy Senator
Rand Paul was that first senator to test
positive for the corona virus do we know
how we got it and who we might have
given it to well it's hard to know for
sure but we do know that he attended
an event in early March in his home
state of Kentucky where two attendees
later tested positive for coronavirus
now Senator Paul says he didn't interact
with those guests so he didn't self
quarantine at the time in fact while he
was waiting for his test results he had
lunch with his fellow Republicans he
interacted with reporters here on the
hill even worked out yesterday in the
Senate gym and swam in the Senate pool
some of his colleagues didn't take too
kindly to that in fact Senator Lindsey
Graham of South Carolina when his
colleagues told us quote I'm not a
doctor but it's pretty obvious to me
that until I got my test back I should
stay away from people and now there are
a couple of senators who are newly in
self quarantine because they came into
such close contact with Senator Paul and
all of that is making it very
complicated as senators prepare to vote
on this massive two trillion dollar
package today hopefully there's a lot of
chlorine in that pool Nancy thank you
very much appreciate it